vous savez je pense que les français ne
sont pas des gosses et qu' ils sont
capables d'accepter des décisions dès
lors qu'elles sont justifiées
compréhensible et sur la question du
port du masque en extérieur dans des
lieux qui ne sont pas dans ce jeu n'est
toujours pas compris quelle était la
justification sanitaires et je crois que
1 des hommes des drames de cette période
c'est que le gouvernement a considéré
qu'il pouvait imposer tout et n'importe
quoi aux français y compris ceux qui
n'étaient pas censés sur la question des
masques observé le même gouvernement les
mêmes personnes les mêmes interlocuteurs
qui hier disait qu'il ne fallait pas de
masques sont aujourd'hui ceux qui disent
qu'il le faut par tous qui avez
plusieurs éditions la ville seulement
pas seulement comment voulez vous que la
confiance existe encore le drame
aujourd'hui de la parole politique c'est
qu'elle ne porte plus de confiance et
s'est singulièrement le cas pour
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
l'enjeu c'est de choisir entre la loi de
la rue et la loi de la république
lorsqu'on s'attaque un commissariat en
étant aussi impuni c'est qu'on s'attaque
à la république et j'ajoute à cela qu'il
faut retravailler sur les peines
incompressibles sur les prennent les
peines qui qu'on appelle les peines
planchers les peines minimales
dès lors qu'on s'attaque un uniforme et
donc à l'autorité de la république
on doit le soir dormir en prison et ne
pas avoir de remise de peine je trouve
que gérald darmanin et marlène schiappa
se marient très bien politiquement les
deux ont un goût très prononcé pour les
tweets pour le blabla pour le bar à
thème politique mais pas du tout pour
l'action gérald darmanin c'est un bon
ministre sur twitter et c'est un très
mauvais ministre l'intérieur dans les
actes